sylvie parler des animaux vous êtes
médium spécialiste dans la communication
animale et il paraît que vos animaux de
compagnie nos animaux de compagnie vous
raconte des choses c'est à dire dès
qu'il vous voit il vous parle mais on
aboie donc bien c'est comme ça non c'est
comme ça c'est en fait ils parlent tous
toi dans way et après ces mêmes mesurer
scientifiquement c'est que on est
capable de le capter ou pas après c'est
une question dont vous vous l'animal
pour vous parler ils vous parlent comme
nous séduire baumann
alors il faut pas ils volent celles d'en
face avant
bayer oui me parle comme comme là on
peut on peut se plaindre comme moi voilà
pareil ah ouais d'accord et et vous avez
des animaux chez vous oui et vous savez
quoi
j'ai une chatte avoir un petit animal
je connais le château sur deux
c'est vrai les animaux le chat la chatte
le chien la chaîne on connaît vous allez
pouvoir donc parler avec les chiens qui
sont inscrits entre autres et ils vont
vous révéler des choses sur nos invités
sur voilà sur les personnes qui sont
avec moi par exemple on a je crois le
chien de jean michel mr et là est-ce
qu'on peut le faire rentrer ou lorsqu'il
entendit s'appelle edgar voilà vous
l'entendez dissidia
il est passé le maquillage de chiens
sébastien sylvie vous voulez la voir
dans les bras voulais qu'ils viennent
vous l'amener à côté de vous pas à côté
alors jean michel baudy prendre votre
chien vous mettez à côte et il vit allez
merci voilà ça m'a pas trop merci à
l'elysée aujourd'hui vous l'aimez vous
l'avez votre chien savant neuf ans neuf
ans alors prenez le dans vos bras et
maïté l'eau à côté de chez lui et si
cette vie et on va voir si jean michel
vous dites la vérité sur jean-michel
elle parle avec les chiens sylvie mou
alors allons-y
eh bien s'ils vivent par les quais de
gare attendez ça ma loge possible web à
ses lèvres et tout ce qu'il dit tout ce
qui peut vous dire edgar et gars qu'est
ce que tu as au peut le faire ça me
tient edgar il me dit qu'il est très
fusionnelle avec son sont humains sont
maîtres humains le comprennent très bien
ouais il habite paris sombre
edgar il me dit que alors dans paris je
sais pas où ça exactement est ce qu'il
ya un petit endroit où éventuellement il
fait ses besoins ouais bah comme tous
les chiens on ne fait pas chez moi c'est
ça que voulait bien est ce qui fait un
endroit toujours pareil genre chez pas
petite cour petit jardinet ou un truc
comme ça ou pas dit oui oui passe pas
mal d'acteurs france oui vous aiderez
faudrait nettoyer de temps en temps ça
me voyant son fondateur la demande du
chien je transmets on n'abuse pas série
mana il est mignon mais non à l'arrivée
le pot ils vont être lavés il en a marre
et les chiens chats se lave pas beaucoup
c'est autrement mais ils perdent leur
l'heureux d'accord mais là c'est là
qu'il faut nettoyer de topal et non s'il
a un endroit où william atteby garçons
voilà qu'est ce qui vous dit sur son
maître qu'est ce que tu veux tu me dis
que tu es traduit pas de secret trop
venir des prénoms féminins ne s'est pas
il ya une histoire de deux grosses
peluches ou je sais pas quoi c'est vous
bah oui un peu grosse qui existent que
j'ai trouvé trois mètres 40 en hausse de
3,40 à distance à lassa apparu chez moi
au lieu dit non mais l on croyait
d'avion viennent plus jeunes 3 yamaha
après celui ressenti donc
l'animation fut ne nous convient pas
enfin ça passe par du ressenti qu'est ce
qui vous dit d'autres c'est les millions
il est mignon mais ça c'est tout ce
qu'ils vous disent ils c'est une police
qui nous parle de certaines delphine qui
serait bientôt la maison
l'ancienne miss france miss mendes qui
vous parle il ya beaucoup de filles il
vous dit qu'il ya des filles qui vont
suivre michel ou pas du tout pouvait
tout dire ouais
il me dit que ça serait bien que quand
une des dames viennent nous fasse
attention à lui aussi c'est un autre
plan
[Applaudissements]
ghazi aridi on va y aller bon bah tant
débat oui il ya les éperons d'or à
benjamin castaldi a fait les chercheurs
étudiants à lire sur les photos vous le
faites aussi à partir de photos oui je
le fais à distance à sans problème j'ai
pas je suis pas obligé d'avoir l'animal
à côté des halles et la majorité de mes
clients c'est à 10 ans d'accord c'est
faux alors qu'elle y a les yeux à celles
évoquées litres c'est vous alors qu'eddy
c'est le chien qui lie à prendre action
benjamin castaldi dit tout ce que vous
dit le chien de kelis est tombé puisque
si fou ce qu'elle a dit chip sur
benjamin comment il s'appelle voiture en
vie dont il me serait une grande seconde
alors moi je pense que rosie c'est une
petite cave soit hier oui mais là comme
n'en est pas question qu est ce qu elle
a redit j'ai aussi besoin de me coincer
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est parce que
c'est pas voilà c'est sérieux
rosie donc elle me dit enfin je ressens
une petite cachotière elle aime bien
cacher les choses se cacher au civil et
du coup on peut voir des choses des fois
qu'elle n'a pas à voir
[Applaudissements]
voici le droit de dire où je me faire
des amis
quel poids et badoit des gens nus
furlatt se cache dans le nid non ah bah
oui est belle dans la croix c'est dingue
c'est quoi le truc qu'elle voit ouais
moi après doha que oui donc elle voit
des gens les verts c'est à dire qu'elle
se cache donc quant aux webmails à
taiwan il se cache sous ma ds et sur la
gêne qui
[Rires]
avec quatre ans qu'elle y invite un
garçon à la maison excusez la gêne rosie
oui pas du tout elle adore comme ça elle
se cacher à voit tout ce qui se passe va
tomber en même temps quand on voit
combien de personnes qui les louent les
animaux ils ont un jardin molière et
donc qu'est ce qu'elle voit d'autres
c'est parce que ça déjà c'était pas mal
c'est énorme c'est vrai ça kelly c'est
possible ça c'est probable non mais
c'est à dire quand vous amenez un regard
sur la maison il ya le chien est le
chien qui est sous la couette
bah si on dort oui elle dort les îles et
dans le calme quoi si tu dois parier là
aussi il fait tout comme toi en ce
moment elle est peut-être un petit peu
jalouse du temps que vous consacrez à
vous préparer
aweys et une odeur qui lui
et éventuellement plaît pas trop
peut-être bien de moi dans la
préparation alors je sais pas du
maquillage ou du vernis peut-être fort
possible elle aimerait bien avoir un peu
enfin le temps s'équilibre un peu
d'accord parce qu'ils trouvaient les
demandes des animaux je moi je dis oui
bah oui c'est fort probable non mais
écoutez oui je me mets de la lacc donc
oui peut-être que ça ça la dérange
jaurès que tout ce qu'il a dit est verni
la dérange pas qu'on va être triste
habitat une autoroute un peu cheap ça
c'est vrai à l'image avec le trolley
c'est fou parce que pour l'instant c'est
vraiment tout était vrai et c'est
maintenant je connais pas le chien de
johnny
[Rires]